it was almost like the way i explained  it to someone recently was it was almost  like someone woke me up like they tapped  me on the shoulder like hey by the way  take it easy it's okay and i was like  what what and then for two months i had  to process it that was probably about i  don't know time is irrelevant with the  way the world's been the last two years  but probably about two years ago and  since then whenever i'm not filming and  for no particular reason people like oh  why don't you do it when you film it i  just don't it's just one of my weird  habits when i'm not filming i probably  partake in it five of the seven days a  week and you feel like it calms you it  relaxes you it opens you what are you  feeling when it's working it's changed  my whole life